- So, thanks, it's good to be here today.
So, like Fran said, I've
worked for about eight years
in digital marketing and strategy
and there's so much
happening in the space.
When I first joined Weber,
every two years we would
reevaluate our offerings
and what we were doing,
and then it seemed like, okay,
we're rethinking things every month,
and now it's like every six months
we're rethinking what we're offering.
And everything that's
on the screen right now,
we could spend the entire 50 minutes
talking about any of them.
But today I'm gonna pick five of these
that I think might be relevant
to Yale sort of holistically
and I'm gonna talk about
them at a pretty high level
because of the amount
of time that we have,
so I'm gonna move pretty fast
and I will get you out there
for your drinks in time.
This is actually my second
time presenting here.
Last time I came I spoke
about content marketing
and how do you operationalize
a content marketing team,
and the biggest piece of feedback I got
was that I was speaking too
much from a corporate lens
and not enough for how things
could be applied at Yale.
So at the end of every section
I have a couple of thought-starters
on what these trends might mean for Yale,
and hopefully a few of those
land and resonate with you.
If not, happy to answer
questions at the end.
So, the first thing that I
wanna start with today is
a story about stories.
The title of this presentation
is "Digital Trends: New, Now and Next".
This is very much a now category,
not something that's coming next.
This is really something
that we are considering
a new best practice that
everyone has gotta grapple with
and have a really strong handle on.
And when I say stories I don't mean
narrative and storytelling,
I mean stories as a technical
format for conveying content.
So, one of the ways that I know
that I'm getting really old in this space
is that I now work with people
who have no recollection of
whole eras of the Internet
that were vital to my career,
and I think this is something
that is about to fall into that category
when I deal with some of the interns
and new people that we hire.
If you think back 10 years ago
when smartphones were just achieving
some kind of a critical mass
of penetration in the market,
everyone was thinking about
how you do video on smartphones
and everyone was doing what they always do
with a new technology,
they were taking the old format,
the old conventions from
film and TV and broadcast
and just slapping them
into the new format.
And as a result we have a lot of people
really awkwardly flipping their phones
to view things sideways,
unfortunate incidents
when the sides of content
is getting cut out,
and it's very much a
not-native format of video
for the platform.
Fast forward to today, times have changed.
Whereas 10 years ago people
would not have even thought
about filming content vertically,
and in fact I've had many conversations
with film production people
where they don't want to
shoot content vertically
because it is so against the aesthetic
that they were trained with,
now people are very much embracing
that as a format overall.
People are spending huge chunks of time
on mobile more so than desktop
more and more every year.
Stories are becoming the
true native application
of video on mobile.
And just looking around I'm guessing
that everyone has a pretty good idea
of what I mean when I say
stories, but just in case.
Stories are a video format
that combines video components,
emoji overlays, typography,
additional graphics
into a series of static and
moving images that tell a story.
And just a quick little
example of what they're like.
This is one that Honda did.
This is actually very
simple as far as stories go.
It's just one video, there's
a few different overlays,
the emojis are playing a key role.
Some of them can actually
get quite complex.
And the story about stories is
that this is something
that started with Snapchat.
This was one of the key
features that Snapchat used
as a differentiator against
other social networks,
Facebook, Twitter, Instagram,
that it was competing with.
Facebook stole the format.
They integrated it into
the core Facebook app.
Most significantly they
made it a key piece
of Instagram's functionality.
That's one of the things
that caused Instagram
to explode in popularity
over the last few years.
At the same time they
kneecapped Snapchat's growth
and were able to keep them
as a second-tier competitor
rather than someone who could truly steal
a lot of market share from Facebook.
But Facebook isn't the
only that has taken it.
Twitter has a version of this,
WhatsApp has a version of this.
When we think about
across messaging platforms
and social platforms, the
use of stories is exploding.
Last year, in their Q4 reporting,
Instagram reported that on a daily basis,
half, 500 million of
their one billion users,
were using stories on a daily basis.
So they're either creating
stories themselves
or they're interacting with stories
that their friends have created.
So, when you think about
the types of content
that you need to be
sending out into the world
to reach your audiences,
stories is very quickly becoming
one of the dominant forms
across all social platforms.
And so, very quickly,
what could this potentially mean for Yale?
If you are in charge with
running communications programs
that reach out to students
or prospective students,
that 100% means mobile and video,
and at this point I
assume most people know
that those two things are vital
to any communications campaign
aimed at a younger audience,
but it also means stories.
If you're just doing link share posts
or graphics or traditional video,
you're missing out on a huge opportunity
to talk to these audiences in a native way
and you really need to start thinking
about how you're going to
experiment with stories
over the next year.
I think when people first see stories
and process what they are,
they go towards this place
of thinking of stories
as just a new evolution
of fast snackable content
for a generation that
has a shorter and shorter
attention span.
I don't think that's actually correct.
Certainly there are some applications
that fall into that realm,
but if you look at what
news organizations are doing
on Instagram, on Facebook, on Snapchat.
Institutions like Vox are doing
really interesting things,
taking the ability of stories
to string multiple different
content pieces together.
So, think opening with a
title card moving to a video,
moving into a graphic of some kind,
moving into a type of graphic
statement back to a video.
And they're actually
finding really engaging
long-form uses for stories
where you can talk about
really complex topics
through a content format
that maybe you weren't quite thinking
would be able to bear
that much information.
So, when you think about how
you might use stories this year
don't just think about
students and brand affinity
and raising awareness and short,
really quick snappy things.
Think about how it might also apply
to longer form, more complex
topics that you want to convey
but you want to get out to audiences
on all of the different channels,
not just in a written text
or the types of formats
that you would usually
think of for long form.
Live streaming is the new social.
When I got into digital marketing
and advertising and strategy,
it was the golden era of blogs,
so I'm very much of the techno utopian
democratization of everything.
Not that I believe any of that anymore
after the last two years.
But I think what we saw happen was
as blogging and those technologies faded,
social came onto the scene.
You have Mark Zuckerberg talking about
the way that Facebook and social
facilitates community
building and gathering,
and I think we've all seen
that that is not actually true
in a lot of instances lately.
But one of the things that
I'm really interested in
is the way the there are
some new applications of live streaming
that may actually be able to bring back
just a little bit of that
hope that there could be
a true community platform
enabled by technology.
So, before we get into
what that actually is,
some background.
Over the last year,
streaming and over-the-top
delivery systems for media
have started to surpass
paid TV and broadcast
in terms of total number of subscribers.
If you look at the growth of
cord-cutters and cord-nevers,
these are people who
have either gotten rid
of their traditional TV and cable packages
or have never actually
had cable and TV packages
'cause they're getting
it all over the Internet.
These are continuing grow.
And these types of streaming applications
are becoming the dominant
way that people get
what we have traditionally thought of
as programs, televised media.
So, these platforms are starting to gain
a majority share of the market
over the traditional vehicles.
At the same time,
they're also starting
to dominate creatively.
So, last year was the first year
where the streaming services,
Amazon, Hulu, Netflix,
actually commissioned and
produced more TV shows
than all the broadcast networks combined.
So, we're now at a place
where the dynamic has completely flipped
and streaming is now the
dominant and natural way
that people are taking
in that type of media.
Social platforms are seeing this.
It's been no secret that
for a really long time
Facebook's goal from an
advertising perspective
has been to steal away the dollars
that would traditionally go to television
and realize that as its own revenue.
We've seen over the last
year a number of platforms,
Facebook, Instagram, all trying to launch
their own version of streaming television.
And if you take a look
at total number of users,
which is what this chart shows right now,
it seems like they're winning.
There's more people who are streaming
and watching that type of program
plus pure, raw,
user-created live streaming
than on digital streaming
subscription services,
TV networks or site apps or
even gaming applications.
But this is all a lie, actually.
This data is fuzzy.
Facebook would love for
you to believe it's true
but it's only part of the story.
Even though they have
more people by volume
than some channels,
I think the future of live streaming
isn't necessarily going
to be the social platform,
it's going to be Twitch.
It's going to be places
like Netflix, YouTube, Hulu,
they're actually getting a
lot more time and engagement
with these audiences
than the Facebooks and the
Instagrams of the world.
And Twitch in particular
I think is poised to
dominate in this space,
not necessarily on the
programmed media side
but on the raw, live
stream, user-created side.
So, for those of you who
don't know what Twitch is,
Twitch is a live streaming platform
that's available on all devices.
It's made its reputation
on the back of e-sports.
People who play video
games professionally go on,
play each other, stream
themselves playing these games,
and while they're playing
there's a running live chat
with all the people who follow them
and they're engaging with
conversation with those people.
They're reading the comments,
those people are
interacting with each other,
with the streamer.
There's some really
interesting subscription
and incentive infrastructure built in
to allow people to support creators
and pay them and tip them.
There's interesting incentives
that the creators and streamers
can send back down into the community
to support their loyal followers.
And what we've seen over
the past few years is
not only are people spending
huge amounts of time on this platform,
there are genuine communities forming
around these games,
around these streamers,
that for the moment don't
have some of the same problems
that we're seeing in terms
of community formation
and public discussion and
bullying issues, trolls,
people coming in to poison the dialogue.
For the moment that hasn't
really happened at Twitch.
But at the same time I think
even though that's how Twitch
has become the platform that it is,
that's not what Twitch sees
as the future of the platform.
It's always gonna be an important piece,
but Twitch itself wants to become
the platform for all live streaming
for a whole variety of communities,
from musicians to people
who right now are doing
beauty blogging on Instagram or YouTube,
DIY, politics, travel.
Twitch wants to be the place
where anyone who has a
use for live streaming
and wants to build a community
can come and make that
platform their home.
And so far we're actually
seeing some success there.
There's been really
interesting experiments
by The Washington Post
and news organizations
to jump on the platform and
create their own streams.
Amateur musicians are
coming on the platform
and building their own communities
and finding ways to support
creation of their songs.
Nike and other brands are
coming onto the platform
to both support the e-gamers
and piggyback off of the
streams that they're doing
but also find new and interesting ways
to run their own streams on the platform.
And as we get into the 2020 election cycle
I think there's going to be
no shortage of live events
that are right for streaming
and I think it's gonna be
really interesting to see
if Twitch can have a breakout moment
in the politics and news space
and not just the e-sports community.
And when that happens I think
it'll be interesting to see
can they actually deal
with all of the problems
that we've seen on social media
that are inevitably gonna get poured over
into that platform as well.
So, what does this mean for Yale?
Start thinking about a live
content streaming strategy.
I'm sure you guys have
live streaming strategies,
you guys do tons of events like this.
I'm sure there's no shortage
of streams happening
on owned channels for Yale.
But what is your live
streaming channel strategy
off Yale channels?
What would you do if you had to go
and leverage something like Twitch
in order to meet an
audience where they are
and not expect them to come to you?
I think over the next year
everyone should be watching
Twitch to see what happens.
There's going to be so many
experiments on the platform
by brands, by politicians.
It's gonna be really interesting to see
where they can break
through and what takes off
versus is it gonna just be a blip
and be purely relegated
to this e-sports space.
And lastly, as you think
about your strategy,
don't just think, oh, I'm gonna go
and create my own live stream on Twitch.
There are lots of interesting
creators on the platform
and there's lots of ways to
piggyback off of those creators.
I think one of the more interesting
things that I've seen is
climate scientists have
actually been piggybacking
onto the live stream of gamers.
They'll talk to someone
who has a following,
they'll play a game
like Fortnite with them,
and they will talk about
climate change science
with the gamer while
they're playing Fortnite
so that they're able to reach
that broader community of people
who are used to following that streamer.
Number three, rise of
the machine interfaces.
So, I think the big headline point here is
we're living through probably
one of the biggest changes
in user interfaces in 30 years.
If you think back we had the introduction
of the graphical user interface.
Things were pretty static for a long time.
We got mobile.
Mobile for the longest time
didn't even have its own native formats,
we're just getting to that now,
it was just a reapplication
of what we had from desktops
into a smaller screen.
But now we're actually starting to see
much more native applications
of how we deal with a mobile-first world,
and I wanna talk through
a few of those things,
a few of those interfaces
and what they mean.
But first I think it's
important to note that
messaging and one-to-one or
one-to-few communications
has started to overtake social media.
So, what you're seeing here,
the big four messaging platforms
back in I think it was, yeah, 2015
crossed over and have more daily users
than the social platforms,
and that is growing and is
probably going to keep growing.
This is driven in many ways by Asia
but we in the West are starting
to catch up more and more.
And I think nowhere do you see this more
than in the way Facebook
is pivoting right now.
If you think about all the things
that they've announced lately,
one the most significant is
that they're going to integrate
WhatsApp, Messenger, and
Instagram on the backend
to essentially create one
interoperable messaging system.
And in part they're doing that
because those messaging platforms
are private and encrypted,
and if more people are moving over
towards messaging platforms,
Facebook wants to be there.
And if that can be in a
private and encrypted format,
Facebook doesn't have to deal
with all of the content
challenges that it has right now
'cause it can't see the content
that's going over those networks.
So if people are bullying,
if there's misinformation campaigns,
Facebook is technically
unable to even intervene
in the way that a lot of
the policy discussions
are happening right now.
So that's one reason.
It's gonna solve the moderation
challenges they have.
But the other piece is that they see
the way that user habits are changing.
They look at WeeChat in Asia
and see how it has become
the one platform where everything happens.
If you're a user of WeeChat in Asia,
you can use it to order
food, you can get your car,
you can order a movie or plane tickets,
you can shop, you can
chat with your friends.
Everything is plugged
into the messaging system
and everything, including commerce,
can happen through that platform.
Facebook wants to be the
one that's in the position
to be the WeeChat of the West
and I think that's also
another reason you see them
starting to dip their toe
into the crypto space.
It would be great if they could have
their own currency within the platform
to help negotiate all
of those transactions.
But this is actually a big problem
for brands, corporations,
institutions like Yale.
We do not have as advanced
the messaging platform
as they do in Asia here,
and if you're trying to reach people
on these messaging
platforms, it's really hard.
It is not like a plug-and-play add system
or just being able to get up organically
and hope people find you on the platform.
Those opportunities are not
nearly as robust in messaging
here as they are in Asia,
so that is a conundrum
that a lot of brands
are gonna have to start dealing with.
Pivoting, I promise this
is not a non sequitur.
At the same time, we're
seeing AI begin to transform
whole industries and
sectors of the economy.
At Weber Shandwick we
really looked at this
as an analytics opportunity first,
and the chart that you
see here from McKinsey
is actually sizing the
analytics opportunity of AI.
I know it's hard to read, I'll spare you.
The upshot is hundreds
of billions of dollars
in potential value to
be unlocked through AI
just in the analytics
space across industries.
But when you think about
marketing and communications
inclusive of but beyond analytics,
McKinsey thinks there's a
$1-2 trillion opportunity
to be unlocked there as well.
And that's everything from
ways that AI can assist
with better content personalization,
upgrading service functions.
There are lots of ways that AI
can aid in communication plans.
So, why am I talking about that
and what is the connection to messaging?
It's chatbots.
What we're seeing right now
is that AI-driven chatbots
are really the initial touchpoint
where these two trends are coming together
in a way that's really
impactful for our clients.
So, more and more consumers
want to interact with brands
through messaging systems.
They don't wanna deal with phone trees
and terrible personal customer service.
They don't wanna go and navigate websites
where the logic isn't
constructed according to the way
that they want to interact with the brand
or how their questions
need to be answered.
They want a very simple system
where they can ask questions,
questions can be answered,
and they can get to the thing
that they need to get to
as fast as possible.
And chatbots, particularly chatbots
that are leveraging natural
language processing in AI
to understand intent and sentiment
and connect that back up to a
potential bank of responses,
those are the places where we're seeing
really successful engagements
and a really successful application
in bringing AI and messaging together
in a way that solves
that messaging challenge
in terms of how you reach people
through that type of a platform.
And even the best chatbot
is still going to be,
for now at least, screen and text-based.
But that is also not the way
that things are trending overall
when we think about user interfaces.
We're seeing more and more
people are interacting through voice.
So, right now more than
1/2 of the US population
actively uses voice assistance
either through their phone
or through a smart speaker in the home.
Excuse me.
And this is starting to radically alter
both the search market
and the way people expect to interact
with technology and with brands.
So, Comscore estimates that by next year
50% of all searches are
gonna be done by voice.
And Gartner says by the end of next year
30% of all those searches
are gonna be on a device
that does not have a screen at all.
So, that creates another
set of challenges.
If you think about what
a search strategy is,
how do you make sure that when
people are asking questions
to a voice assistant,
your results are getting surfaced?
How do you create applications
that can reach and engage
people on those platforms?
We're starting to see
some interesting things
happen in that space.
Two in particular that seem
to be successful so far
is customer service.
We've seen some companies,
particularly energy utilities,
put together customer service applications
that can be activated by
voice on home speakers
and walk you through any
problem that you're having,
and they've also been
using it for bill pay.
So, very common customer interactions,
they're going out, finding
new ways to get people
through what can often
be frustrating processes
faster using new technology.
And so, what does that mean at Yale?
I think it's a few very
disparate things, actually.
So, I'm sure a lot of you are
in charge of social strategy
for different functions within Yale.
So, how is your social
strategy going to evolve
as audiences stop using social
and move over to messaging?
What are you gonna do when
it's harder to reach them
because the platforms are less open,
less conducive to mass communication?
When we think about
leveraging AI, chatbots,
what are you doing on a regular basis
that can be routinized and automated?
What are the frequently asked questions
that your department gets all of the time
that are either buried in web pages
or take an inordinate amount
of a real person's time
to run down when they're
getting them all the time?
These are places where some
kind of automated solution
like a chatbot or a messaging application
can actually solve those problems,
give you a better experience to users,
and free up your staff time
to do more strategic things
or take the people who really
need the one-on-one help
and go a lot deeper and
have a much higher level
of that personal customer
service over fewer interactions
rather than spreading themselves thin
over a large number of interactions.
And lastly, how is your
SEO strategy gonna evolve
as voice captures more and
more of the search market?
It's not gonna be about
optimizing around keywords,
to the extent that your pages
are constructed correctly.
That always helps but
people are asking questions.
Right now they're asking questions
about the weather and news and sports
but soon they're gonna be asking
questions about everything.
And are you ready to get
served in the top result
for a particular question
that is gonna be relevant
to you as an institution
and the people that you wanna talk with?
So, fake everything.
This one's probably
pretty self-explanatory.
I think we've all seen the
issues over the past years.
We have Russian bots manipulating
political conversations.
We have bots in fraud on the ad side.
We have the potential for deepfakes
to disrupt political conversation,
or we are one deepfake away
from a company's bottom
line getting tanked.
And even the stuff we saw
around Nancy Pelosi just a few weeks ago
with the altered video, what
people would call a cheap fake,
it's not even a real deepfake,
it's just been slightly altered,
can cause a huge amount of problem.
And we're even seeing some
interesting things happen,
it's not all negative,
we're seeing some interesting
positive fake things happening too,
like the growth of what people
are calling fake influencers
but are actually almost like
digital AI mascots for brands.
And these are just a few
influencers that are not real
but are just as influential
as many celebrities are today.
So, there's a lot going on in this space.
It probably feels like
we've reached peak fake
but I think it's actually
gonna get a lot worse
before it gets better.
And that's a challenge for our
clients and for institutions.
In this environment,
current listening solutions
are pretty inadequate.
For the most part when you ask people,
how are you monitoring
what people are saying?
How are you able to know whether
something is real or fake?
People will tell you, "Oh,
we're using Brandwatch,"
or, "We're using Sysomos
or Crimson Hexagon."
And that's great, but are
they going deep enough
to really understand what is happening
and where conversations are coming from?
'Cause conversations
are not just happening
on Facebook and Twitter
and YouTube and Google,
there is whole other
layers to the Internet
and conversations are
starting way down deep,
hidden away from most people,
and they are percolating up
before you see them go
viral on the main networks.
And the challenge is by the
time it gets to the main network
if you are a company that is,
if you are a company that is
being attacked in some way,
if you're a politician or a government
that's being attacked,
by the time it gets to the main networks,
it's too late, all you can do is react.
You have no chance of
limiting the conversation,
redefining the framework
of the conversation.
Your ability to proactively
dampen the effect
is already gone.
So, the thing that we're
seeing companies do
in response to this
is really level up their
listening capabilities,
and the way that they're doing that
is what we're calling media forensics.
It's a set of processes and tools,
it's a combination of AI and machines
with human experts who
can do real research
and understand what the
machines are uncovering
and going to places that the
machines can't actually go.
If you think back to all
of the different platforms,
the iceberg in that slide,
a lot of them have APIs
that can be scraped
by listening services,
a lot of them don't.
A lot of them you have to
have a real person inside
who understands the
cultures of the platform
investigating what's happening.
And we're seeing companies
bring these two things together
to start to understand
not just where things come
from and how they've spread
but also as a warning system
that something may be coming
and they're going to need
to have a response to it
in some way.
Just a quick example of how
this has worked in the past.
So, everyone probably
recognizes Emma Gonzalez,
the Parkland's activist.
She was on a Teen Vogue cover shoot
with a few of her fellow activists
and she was shown ripping up
this picture of a gun target.
And way down in some forums
that gun right advocates congregate in,
they photoshopped the target
into a picture of the Constitution.
They started to spread that privately
through their own networks.
It started to percolate up into
Reddit and some other places
that then people took it up
and spread it into Twitter, Facebook,
and eventually it blew
up and got on the news.
So, it's just an example
of how misinformation
can percolate through all of those levels,
and media forensics is a way to
if necessary backtrack through those steps
and understand what happened
or hopefully proactively see it
before it breaks out
and (mumbles) respond.
So, it is very much a crisis
mitigation and prevention tool
but I think it also goes beyond that.
So, more and more consumers
are pushing companies
to take stands on social issues.
People want to be engaged with companies
that are active socially and politically,
and this is putting
companies in a bit of a bind.
There's lots of hashtags and memes
and things that are flying
around on social all of the time.
How do you know whether something is right
for you to jump onto or not?
Do you understand the
full provenance of an idea
that is going viral on the web?
And one of the best examples
that I've ever seen of this is
this reporting by The New York Times.
If you haven't read it I highly
recommend you go and find it
and take a look at it later today.
It takes like 10 minutes to get through.
It's less intimidating
than it looks at times.
But what they did was took
a look at this phrase,
"jobs not mobs," and they
traced the evolution of it
from right-wing forums over onto Reddit
where it was picked up by Scott Adams,
the cartoonist who created Dilbert,
promoted onto his social channels,
picked up by Fox News and
then eventually tweeted out
by the President of the United States.
So, again, it's about
understanding the full context
of where something comes from
and how the conversations
that we're having as a
society are developing
so that you can evaluate
whether or not it makes sense
for you to be in that conversation or not
or at least have a game plan
for responding to that conversation
if it's something that's directed
at you as an organization.
And so, what it means at Yale?
I think this is very much in line
with what we typically tell our clients.
So, what is your monitoring
solution right now?
How deep does it go?
What can it tell you,
what can't it tell you?
I think it's worth taking
a moment to understand
what it's capable of and what
your need is for going deeper
and having a different
solution than what you have.
Explore scenarios in which fake content
might damage your reputation.
People that work in public affairs
or issues management positions,
I'm sure you have an understanding
of places where Yale might be perceived
as vulnerable or at risk.
What do those scenarios look like
and then how do you game plan those out?
Can you conduct crisis training
to make sure that your response frameworks
are actually something that's workable
and are not gonna fail you
when the moment to deploy
them actually comes.
And how do you create
muscle memory among staff
who maybe are not familiar
with crisis management
and you want them to know
how they're going to react
in the moment when
something like this happens.
I'm doing fantastic on
time, this is great.
So, last one.
This is a new idea so you
guys are my guinea pigs here.
I have not presented this anywhere before.
What I'm calling personal ecosystems
as the new executive equity.
And if executive equity is
too agency jargony of a term for you,
it basically just means how do we promote
and raise the profile of
executives within an organization
through PR, marketing, advertising.
So, I've mentioned this before
but there really is a strong trend
towards consumers wanting CEOs
to be engaged on social right now,
and CEOs starting to hop on social.
We're seeing that consumers
are more likely to trust companies
when they see that their
CEO is active on social
and responding to issues about the company
or things that are happening in the news.
We see that employee engagement
and satisfaction is higher
in companies where CEOs
are engaging in those ways.
And again the consumers are more likely
to want to associate and make purchases
with companies that they
feel are taking a stand
and where they see that active engagement,
particularly from the C-suite.
And all of this really
points to over the next year
an influx of even more
CEOs and C-suite executives
on social media that
are on there right now,
particularly on the
platforms like Twitter,
Facebook and LinkedIn.
And everyone will tell you
you need to have a strategy
for that, and you do.
And my response is, yeah,
but social is not really
the greatest place anymore.
It's a bit of a dumpster fire.
Is that where you want your CEO to engage?
Do you want your CEO exposed
to all of the craziness
and the people that are gonna
come out of the woodwork
and attack?
It's not really a conducive
forum to complex discussions,
as we've found right now.
And the other thing is I
think a lot of executives
who will naturally take to the platform
are probably early adopters
and they're probably already there,
so I do have my own doubts
about whether or not
executives that are
coming on late to the game
are going to be comfortable in the medium
and really put themselves out there
and say things that are interesting enough
to get the kind of traction
that they're hoping to get
through a social program.
Example number one of course is Elon Musk.
A totally native user of social,
has used it to essentially
be a one-man PR shop
that has vastly increased the reputation
of all of its companies.
But of late we've literally seen him
destroy shareholder value with a tweet,
so a bit of a cautionary tale as well
and again something that I think
executives and anyone who's charged
with putting together an
executive equity program
really needs to think about carefully.
At the same time, I am
completely fascinated
by the emergence of slow media.
I think there's a really
interesting creative tension
happening right now in
the media landscape.
So much is pushing towards faster,
more snackable, more
visual types of content.
All of the advertising
and monetary incentives
of the media system are aligned
with pushing for that
faster type of content.
And I think because of all the challenges
we're having social right now
and relative lower trust in the media,
people want to pull back from that.
They don't necessarily want to
engage in all of those things
as much as they did in the past.
And I think we're starting to see
the development of media systems
that are tailored more
towards slower consumption,
deeper engagement on individual topics
and I think this is why
we're seeing newsletters
have a resurgence in popularity
over the last few years.
They're both able to
cut through the clutter
of all of the different things
that are coming in on your social feeds
and give you a curated view
of what is most important.
And a lot of the most
successful newsletters
don't try and boil the
ocean and cover everything,
they go really deep on one topic.
Like Casey Newton's
newsletter for The Verge
that specifically covers Facebook
and tech and privacy issues.
There's an amazing blog slash newsletter
that is about business and
tech called Stratechery.
These are all made for
people who want to spend
a lot more time and thought
on a particular topic.
And I think nowhere
are we seeing this more
than in the rise of
podcasting as a format.
So, podcasting seems like
it's gonna keep growing
really fast year over year.
The ad dollars are starting to
come there as well right now
which bodes well for
the health of podcasting
as an overall media ecosystem.
And as you can see from the chart here,
the amount of time people
are spending with podcasts,
which is a very intimate format
that allows you to go really deep,
really thoughtfully, slowly
on an individual subject,
that's also climbing really fast.
Two hours per day people are
spending listening to podcasts.
We're starting to get into TV territory
in terms of how much of
your time is taking up,
and that's a really great place
for people who want to
get messages out there.
And the way that all
of this comes together
is the personal media ecosystem
for thought leadership.
So, what do I mean by this?
I think the best example is
just journalists themselves.
Journalists can no longer afford
to be employed by one news outlet
where they're writing one column
or just covering one beat,
they need to get themselves out there
in many different formats because A,
it increases their value
to the news organizations
and helps them pull in more money,
but it's also job security
and helps them find new jobs
if the news outlet that they're
at goes under or cuts staff.
They are able to build up personal brands
across multiple channels
that they're able to port
with them wherever they go.
And Bill Simmons is a
fantastic example of this.
He's pretty much the master at it.
So, Bill Simmons, for
those who don't know,
has made his name in sports.
He has founded a wide
variety of media platforms.
He has his own online
magazine called The Ringer.
Before that he had one called Grantland.
He has his own podcast.
He has livestream, or he did live stream
his analysis of Game of
Thrones after every episode.
He has a Facebook Live
that he puts on during sporting events.
Six million followers on Twitter,
177,000 followers on Instagram.
He's got columns on multiple publications.
Esquire, Recode.
He had an HBO TV show for a while.
He has extended his reach
through multiple channels
and really built up a personal brand
and connection with a
wide variety of audiences
that goes really deep on
each of those channels.
And I think this is potentially
a really interesting model
for thinking about executive equity
and thought leadership overall.
So, this is Carla B. PhD, I made her up.
She's not real.
I tried to get an AI-generated fake person
but the aspect ratios didn't work out,
so, she's a stock photo.
But you can imagine
that she is an employee
at a biotech startup in Boston.
She knows a lot about biology.
She knows about startups
'cause she's in a biotech.
She also cares deeply about policy
because how policy is implemented
directly affects her
ability to do her job.
If you are charged with communications
at the company that Carla works at,
you could think about
all of the different ways
you could raise her profile
and get her out there.
You could be getting her
on podcasts as an expert
to be interviewed on science podcasts,
women in tech podcasts.
You could be cultivating
her as an expert source
with The Wall Street Journal
on the business side.
She could have her own Twitter following.
She could be a contributor to
a publication on neuroscience
that exists on Medium called The Spike.
She could be writing a series
of articles on Boston biotech
on LinkedIn and cultivating
an audience there.
She could be someone who
appears on Facebook Live
during company events.
And from a paid perspective,
as you're thinking about sponsored content
on podcasts or on newsletters,
she could be a voice in those channels.
So, I think what's interesting here is
this is something that can be applied
not just to a CEO or
not just to the C-suite.
Expertise in companies
is not just locked up
in those few individuals,
it exists throughout the organization.
She doesn't have to be
the primary spokesperson
that is there on every
channel all the time,
and in fact it's better if she's not.
We have one client that I
have worked on for a while now
where one of the challenges they had
is they have a bunch of
different departments
all of who have experts, all
of who get pitched to media,
and because they all want the same media
they're constantly stepping
over each other's pitches
and it's actually working across purposes
with their communication strategy
and they're essentially
competing with themselves
for the same space in news articles.
If all the experts had
their own tailored plan
for where they were being pitched,
how that was happening
from an owned standpoint,
from an earned standpoint,
from a paid standpoint,
I think the reach of any
one particular individual
would be smaller
but you'd be able to
build up personal brands
for all of these people
that run a lot deeper
and you'd be able to have
a much more effective
media presence overall.
So, what does it mean for Yale?
I think first and foremost, the basics.
Are school leaders and spokespeople
adequately represented on social?
I stand by what I said about social
not necessarily always
being the best place
but it is sort of a
baseline that people expect.
So, then, are you taking
advantage of slow media formats?
And not to convey
content that is snackable
but thinking about the long form
really complex things you have to convey
and the way that those can be vehicles
for those types of communications
in a way that standard
social channels cannot.
And then if you are responsible
for promoting a wide number of people,
maybe it's all of the different
faculty in a department
and their scholarship,
what is the ecosystem strategy
that you could build around
each of those individuals
that want to work with you from
a communications standpoint
to ensure that they're
all getting exposure,
they're all getting the
right level of effort
applied to their communications,
and they're not stepping on each other
trying to secure the same spot
or talk to the same audiences.
And that's it.
I think we've got some time for questions.
Thanks.
(audience applauds)
(gentle music)